they have shifted the Overton window to
the point that if you are a moderate
Centrist of 10 years ago they will now
frame you as a crazy right-wing Maniac I
was on the fresh and fit podcast big
podcast with the young people uh over
here in Miami last week I think we
showed a we showed a clip of it or a
little image of it I want to show you
this one little clip because they were
asking me about my political Evolution
uh and I think we can tie this together
with Elon and sort of everything we've
talked about right here
you could see it right here this is so
Elon tweeted this exact thing so Ben I
don't know if you Ben saw it first or if
this is from after or whatever but you
can see in essence 2018 my fellow
liberal me and then you can see the way
the shift is going the fellow liberal
the progressive now he went bananas left
boys or girls everyone's racist blah
blah blah the me guy he stayed as close
to the center as possible then in the
third one down there in 2021 now the the
liberal is now known as awoke
Progressive and everyone else is a bigot
and the me guy has now in essence been
shifted right and the conservatives
going LOL you see I wasn't so bad after
this is a perfect illustration honestly
of what it is because I've always said
it like a lot of people haven't changed
their views just that the left becomes
more and more and more radical yeah well
they don't they have no sort of off-ramp
you know at every moment where the left
could go all right maybe we should just
ease up let's think about what we Donald
Trump gets elected you might go boy
maybe there's something going on here we
should talk about maybe there's
something wrong with what we're doing
you know orange Hitler is in charge
maybe we should discuss this but they
don't they get more hysterical but the
reason they do is because it's all based
on emotion all right you get it
though those guys get it and let's see
how the rest of this all plays out but
uh as I say once you see it you can't
unsee it that is the uh that is the
disturbing part of the red pill
[Music]
foreign